Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman show,
I am Farron Cousins sitting in for David Pakman
today. And hey, don't forget you can find
me on all my social media accounts Twitter,
Facebook and Instagram. Same name on all of
them at and balanced. That is also the name
of my personal YouTube channel. And of course, you
can find me at youtube.com slash the Ring of Fire.
Let's talk about the January six Select
Committee to round out this day's show, right
after all. It now appears they're going
after sitting Republican members of Congress.
They submitted a request this week to Republican
Congressman Scott Perry, and Perry made headlines
recently when it was revealed that he was one of
the, I guess you'd call it, a ringleader of some
of the other House Republicans who were working
to get the DOJ to intervene and overturn the
results of the 2020 presidential election. Scott
was kind of the ringleader. And now, Mr. Perry,
after the committee said we would like
some documents from you and of course,
we would like for you to sit down and have a chat
with us has announced that no. Not going to do it.
Because he says the committee is somehow
illegitimate and unconstitutional.
Let me read this statement that Perry put
out on Tuesday after deciding he was not
going to work with the committee. I stand
with immense respect for our Constitution,
the rule of law and the Americans I represent
who know that this entity is illegitimate and not
duly constituted under the rules of
the U.S. House of Representatives.
I decline this entity's request and will continue
to fight the failures of the radical left, who
desperately seek distraction from their
abject failures of crushing inflation,
a humiliating surrender in Afghanistan and the
horrendous crisis they created at our border.
Sometimes, folks, sometimes they're
so much stupid. In one statement.
That it hurts, it hurts us to read these things.
It's painful. To have those words come out of my
mouth, even if they're not from me either
from him, I don't like that at all. So.
Let's address a couple of things
real quick here from Mr Perry.
You're calling the Democrats losers, you're saying
they can't get over something. Dude, the reason
they want to talk to you in the first place
is because you tried to overturn the election.
You tried to weaponize the Department of
Justice to do your bidding and illegally,
unconstitutionally. By the way, since you seem to
love the Constitution, overturn the duly elected
government of the United States at the time. So
you don't get to lecture anyone about what is and
is not constitutional. And of course, yes, the
select committee is 100 percent constitutional.
That was actually something I had
discussed in yesterday's program as well,
you know, with Alex Jones lawsuit saying the
committee is not constitutional. No, it is.
Courts have ruled over the years. Yes,
the House of Representatives does,
in fact have this authority going all the
way back to the first basically criminal
inquiry. I guess you could call it that the
house conducted all the way back in 1795.
So learn your history. Scott Perry learned
your Supreme Court cases. Congressman Perry,
so that you won't make such a damn fool of
yourself in the future. But it is what it is,
right, Mr. Perry's doing what he knows, he's
worried, he's panicked. He understands that the
text messages that have already come out from
him are really, really bad and the committee
is doing what they should be doing and now
officially focusing on these members of Congress.
The problem that I have with them
going after these members of Congress
because let's not forget, Jim Jordan was
also involved in this. Gohmert Brooks.
All of these people do need to be investigated,
they do need to be called in front of the
committee, but that's not enough. Heck, we also
need to find out why Lauren Boebert was, you know,
live tweeting Nancy Pelosi's location during all
of this. She'd only been a member of Congress
for at that point, really a matter of hours.
So why was she doing that, so that also needs
to be brought up in front of the committee. The
problem I have is that that's not good enough.
Just bringing these people in front of the
committee, getting your hands on these records.
You know, their call logs, text messages,
whatever it is, and getting their testimony.
We've seen a lot of this already. The problem is,
even if you get horrible information
on any of these individuals,
the most you can do is recommend criminal charges
for them. You're not going to vote to expel them.
And even if you attempted to vote to expel
them, you wouldn't have the votes to do it.
That's what drives me crazy about all of
this. Because these members of Congress
do need to be expelled. It is time for
that. Yes, we can go through due process,
we'll make sure it's all fair, neat and, you
know, cross our TS, dot our eyes, all of that.
But if you ask me personally right now,
I think these people need to be expelled.
I think their actions based on the text
messages that again are already readily
available. I think they rise to sedition. I
think they rise to treason. We are talking
about elected members of Congress. Trying to
convince the Department of Justice to overturn.
What effectively was the government elect
of the United States? There's no ifs,
ands or buts about it, really, when you look
at it that way. That would constitute treason.
Even trying to tell them to do these things
would likely rise to the level of sedition.
So how are these people still serving in
Congress? And the answer is the Republicans.
If the Democrats had the numbers, I would like to
think they would go ahead and vote to expel these
members. I'd like to think that. Heaven only knows
sometimes what the Democrats are actually going to
do. But without those Republican numbers, it's
not going to happen without enough Republicans
standing up and saying this person is so toxic not
just to my party but to the country itself, and I
believe that their behavior does rise to the level
of criminal activity, and I want them gone without
enough Republicans to say that it's not going to
happen. And then, of course, maybe we get charges
referred from this and then maybe these people
get prosecuted and maybe they get convicted.
At this point, we're talking about four or five
years out into the future, probably at that point.
You know, they can serve another what, two and a
half terms in the amount of time that may take.
Think of the damage that these
individuals could do in that time.
It's not good enough. Letting them sit there
while this happens is not good enough, at the
very least, we need some kind of mechanism
to where they could at least be suspended.
And I know there is currently no
mechanism like that in the house.
Maybe that's something we work on. Maybe that's
an amendment to the Constitution. Maybe we throw
that in with the term limit amendment
that I also feel we desperately need.
But until this matter is settled, until these
people cooperate and turn over everything and
the committee finishes its work and issues
its final report, these individuals should
have their votes suspended. They should be
stripped of their committees immediately.
And that should be that that's what we should do.
But again, there's no constitutional mechanism for
that to happen. So we need an amendment to give
Congress the authority to do that, I believe.
I don't think they could just change their own
rules to do that. So that's what needs to happen.